like buses AI news can sometimes be slow
and sometimes arrive all at once in the
last few days we have had dramatic new
leaked insights into the sheer breadth
of Google's Gemini just today we've had
the release of meta's code Lama and
earlier their impressive multilingual
seamless m4t model and last but
definitely not least this 88 page AI
Consciousness report and yes I read it
all it's juicy so I'm saving that for
the end but let's start with two major
pay World articles one from the
information and one from the New York
Times about Google's Gemini model from
both of them I counted a total of nine
New Revelations so let's get straight to
it to give you a sense of timeline by
the way Google's newly merged AI SWAT
team they call it is preparing for a big
fall or Autumn launch the takeaway for
me from both articles is that Gemini is
going to be the everything model did you
know it's going to be the Rival to Mid
journey and stable diffusion mid Journey
only has 11 full-time staff so it is
more than plausible that Google's Gemini
could outperform mid Journey version 5
next we may be able to create graphics
with just text descriptions and Control
software using only text or voice
commands these next two are speculations
so I'm not even counting them in the
list of leaks I've already covered in a
previous video that Gemini has been
trained on YouTube video transcripts and
the speculation is that by integrating
video and audio into Gemini it could
perhaps help a mechanic diagnose a
problem with a car repair based on a
video or be a rival to Runway ml by
generating Advanced text a video based
on descriptions of what a user wants to
see you can start to see why I'm
beginning to think of it as the
everything model another leak is that
one of the co-founders of Google Sergey
Brin is working on on the front lines of
Google Gemini and lastly from this
article I found it really interesting
that Google's lawyers have been closely
evaluating the training and they made
researchers remove training data that
had come from textbooks even though
those textbooks helped the model answer
questions about subjects like astronomy
or biology and I do wonder if they
privately benchmarked Gemini before
removing that crucial textbook data but
if that's not enough prepare to also
receive life advice my theory here is
that Google wants to compete directly
for market share with inflections Pi
what if you want scientific creative or
professional writing Yep they're working
on that too in fact we already know that
Google has software named Genesis that
they're pitching to the New York Times
which can generate news articles rewrite
them suggest headlines Etc but some
people will be more interested in this
feature that Google deepmind is working
on the ability to draft critiques of an
argument and generate quizzes word and
number puzzles it's almost easier at
this point to ask what might Google
Gemini not be able to do and yes this is
not Gemini but Google Deep Mind is also
using AI to design the next generation
of semiconductors but if the fall seems
far away how about today when we got
code llama from meta I spent much of the
last 2 hours reading most of the 47 page
paper and you can see code llama in
action on screen some highlights include
that the code llama models provide
stable generations with up to 100,000
tokens of context obviously that could
be used for generating longer programs
or providing the model with more context
from your codebase to make the
generations more relevant it comes in
three versions code llama code llama
instruct which can better understand
natural language instructions and code
llama python better of course at python
it's available for commercial use and as
you can see some of the versions rival
GPT 3.5 on human eval that top score of
53.7% on pass at one puts it in the same
ballpark as 51 I've actually done a full
video on 51 so do check that out but
that got
50.6% but it is about 25 times smaller
at 1.3 billion parameters interestingly
the code llama paper which also came out
about 2 hours ago mentions F1 directly
saying that it follows in a similar
Spirit but the difference is that fi1 is
closed Source anyway a couple more
interesting things before we move on
from code llama and the first one is the
self- instruct method that they use let
me know if you also find this
fascinating because step one was to
generate 62,000 interview style
programming questions by prompting llama
2 the 70 billion parameter model then
they removed duplicates in step two but
here's where it gets interesting for
each of those questions they first
generated a unit test by prompting code
llama 7 billion parameters then they
generated 10 python solutions by
prompting code llama finally they ran
unit tests on those 10 Solutions and
they added the first solution that
passes those tests along with the
corresponding question and test to the
self- instruct data set if that sounded
a bit complicated let me try to distill
it a bit they asked the Big Brother
llama 2 model to generate questions then
got the little brother code llama to
generate tests for those questions then
got the model to generate solutions to
its own tests found the good solution
that don't forget it produced and then
use those to further train the model to
be honest synthetic data and
self-instructed back one final
interesting quote from the paper on
safety and that was an argument Advanced
by one of their red teamers they made
the point that various scripts and code
is readily available on mainstream
public websites hacking forums or the
dark web and the advanced malware
development is beyond the current
capabilities of available l LMS and even
an advanced llm paired with an expert
malware developer is not particularly
useful at the moment as the barrier is
not typically writing the malware code
itself let me know what you think in the
comments but we must move on to seamless
m4t released a couple of days ago from
meta which frankly seems amazing for
multilingual translation that's Speech
to Text Speech to speech text to text
and more it has speech recognition for
nearly 100 languages and can output in
36 languages but there's one feature I
find particularly
cool now let's talk about code switching
code switching happens when a
multilingual speaker switches between
languages while they are speaking our
model seamless M4 automatically
recognizes and translates more than one
language when mixed in the same sentence
as a multilingual speaker this is a very
exciting capability for me I often
switch from Hindi to delu when I speak
with my dad notice in the following
example when I change
languages
Hindi I can speak Hindi tuug and English
sometimes I use all three languages in
one conversation speaking of cool though
we had this epic story out yesterday AI
gave a paralyzed woman her voice back in
a moment you're going to see her being
plugged in to the model there we go and
the short version is that this woman
suffered a stroke that left her unable
to speak but now for the first time her
speech and facial expressions can be
synthesized from her brain signals
decoding these signals into text at
nearly 80 words per minute up from 14
words per minute but let's now end on
this an 88 page report on Consciousness
in artificial intelligence which counts
as one of its co-authors Yoshua Benjo
the touring Award winner it was dense
and quite technical but well worth the
read look at this sentence in just the
abstract our analysis suggests that no
current AI systems are conscious but
also suggests that there are no obvious
technical barriers to building AI
systems which satisfy these indicators
these are the IND indicators and each
one gets a few pages in the report and
the reason that they're split up is
because each one rests on a certain
Theory Of Consciousness obviously the
key problem is that we don't have a
consensus theory on what Consciousness
is or how it comes about so in a way to
hedge their bets they group in different
theories and look at the kind of
indicators that would satisfy each one
you might say that list seems so
theoretical why not just test the model
or even ask the model for more on that
approach see my theory of Mind video but
the problem is as they say on page four
the main alternative to a theory heavy
approach is to use behavioral tests for
Consciousness but as I talked about in
the other video that method is
unreliable because AI systems can be
trained of course they are to mimic
human behaviors are working actually in
very different ways essentially llms
have broken the traditional tests for
Consciousness including of course the
touring test test the paper also rests
on the Assumption of computational
functionalism essentially that
computations are essential for
Consciousness as in it's not What You're
Made Of it's what you do if this is
wrong and the substrate in fact is key
say biological cells then it stands the
reason that AI would never be conscious
but one of their early conclusions is
that if computational functionalism is
true and it is widely believed conscious
AI systems could realistically be built
in the near term having digested the ENT
entire paper they're strongly suggesting
that we're not there yet but if this
theory is true we could be there
especially if researchers deliberately
designed systems to meet these criteria
in fact here is a key quote from one of
the authors in science that came along
with the piece it would be trivial to
design all of these features into an AI
the reason no one has done so is it is
not clear that they would be useful for
tasks now to be honest it is way beyond
my pay grade to try to explain every
aspect of the paper but I'm going to try
my best to convey the key bits first
what is the definition of Consciousness
that they are working with well skipping
the jargon they essentially say if you
are reading this report on a screen you
are having a conscious visual experience
of the screen that is separated from
sentience which is also sometimes used
to mean being capable of pleasure or
pain and they say that it's possible for
a system to be sentient without being
conscious by sensing its body or
environment and it's possible for a
system to be conscious without sensing
its body or environment it also might be
possible to be slightly conscious or
conscious to a greater degree than
humans Ilia satova famously said it may
be that today's large neural networks
are slightly conscious and Carl Schulman
and Nick Bostrom wrote an entire chapter
of a book on the possibility that models
become more conscious than human beings
they say such beings could contribute
immense value to the world and failing
to respect their interests could produce
a moral catastrophe one of the theories
of Consciousness discussed is recurrent
processing Theory and here is the key
part of that theory One initial
feedforward sweep of activity through
the hierarchy of visual areas is
sufficient for some visual operations
like extracting features from a scene
but not sufficient for conscious
experience however when the stimulus is
sufficiently strong or Salient we get
this looped recurrent processing in
which signals are sent back from higher
areas to lower ones it's only then that
you get a conscious representation of an
organized scene the paper then draws
indicators based on each theory for
example if current processing theory is
accurate then here are two indicators
that something would be conscious they
then draw analogies for each Theory to
AI systems for example on recurrence
specifically algorithmic recurrence they
say that's a weak condition that many AI
systems already meet but don't forget
when they say that it's an analogy not
only does it require the theory to be
correct it requires the analogy to hold
true I is the recurrence that we see in
AI a good analogy for the recurrence of
this Theory or what about the next one
Global workspace theory if that theory
is correct here are four indicators of
something being conscious according to
that theory to be honest if you are at
all interested in Consciousness the
pages on each one of these taught me a
lot about test for Consciousness and
just theories of Consciousness again
let's just say that theory is correct do
AI systems demonstrate these indicators
do they have modules that can work in
parallel and a global workspace at the
center is that workspace bandwidth
limited requiring the compression and
selection of information from the
modules well here again we can only rely
on analogies in this case to the
Transformer architecture they say in a
sense they do have modules they do have
a limited capacity workspace introducing
a bottleneck but then the authors
introduce plenty of points about how the
analogy is not perfect even here of
course you can pause and read the
details if you like or indeed read the
entire paper so that's the tone of the
paper if silicon can be a replacement to
carbon and if these analogies hold then
there is a strong case that most or all
of the conditions for Consciousness
suggested by current computational
theories can be met using existing Tech
techniques in AI this is not to say that
current AI systems are likely to be
conscious there is also the issue of
whether they combine existing techniques
in the right ways but it does suggest
that conscious AI is not merely a remote
possibility in the distant future and
here is the key bit if it is at all
possible to build conscious AI systems
without radically new hardware it may be
possible now of course even if all of
those conditions and analogies hold it
may not be the same type of
Consciousness as our Consciousness it
seems possible that say to imagine a
conscious being that had only a
succession of brief static discret
experiences perhaps just during
pre-training or they might have
experiences without feeling that they
are a persisting subject but my own
summary is this we clearly don't fully
understand Consciousness or what is
required for Consciousness we don't know
if Consciousness in AI systems is
theoretically impossible or imminent the
authors actually quote this open letter
from the association for math ma matical
Consciousness science and in it at the
end the letter says we emphasize that
the rapid development of AI is exposing
the urgent need to accelerate research
in the field of Consciousness science
even if we develop a system that ticks
all of these indicators and trust me
someone is probably working on that
right now we still won't know for sure
and many people will deny forever that
that system is conscious I'm not
claiming I have the answer by the way I
have absolutely no idea if these systems
are imminently conscious already
conscious or will never be conscious all
I can say is that it's a bit less sci-fi
than many people believe and the authors
also point out two risks under
attributing Consciousness to AI playing
down the possibility but they also point
out the risk of over attributing
Consciousness to AI on under attributing
Consciousness they say this given the
uncertainties about Consciousness
mentioned above we may create conscious
AI systems long before we recognize that
we have done so and I see this sentence
as a fateful prediction this tendency is
further Amplified when AI systems
exhibit humanlike characteristics such
as natural language processing which
they already do but also facial
expressions or adaptive learning
capabilities so imagine what people are
going to think when photorealistic AI
avatars are everywhere and finally there
is the risk of experimentation itself on
balance we believe that research to
better understand the mechanisms which
might underly Consciousness in AI is
beneficial however of course research on
this topic runs the risk of building or
enabling others to build a conscious AI
system which should not be done lightly
and that mitigating this kind of risk
should be carefully weighed against the
value of better understanding
Consciousness in Ai and to tie this back
to the start of the video Google's AI
safety experts have added that some
users who grew too dependent on this
technology could think it was sentient
and I do wonder if that's an eventuality
Google's newly merged AI SWAT team is
preparing for as always thank you so
much for watching to the end and have a
wonderful day oh and just quickly before
I end I now have a Discord AI explain
Community more info in the description